This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. It used to be that if you wanted to feel what it was like to do something, you had to go out and do it. If your dream was to see the Grand Canyon from a raft, you'd head to the river. If you wanted to gaze up close at the Mona Lisa, you'd go to Paris. If you wanted to know what it felt like to walk hand in hand with a lover on a moonlit night, you'd have to go out and find a partner. wanted to know what it felt like to walk hand in hand with a lover on a moonlit night. You'd have to go out and find a partner.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。过去，如果你想感受做某件事是什么感觉，你必须亲自去做。如果你的梦想是乘木筏看大峡谷，你会去到河边。如果你想近距离凝望《蒙娜丽莎》，你会去巴黎。如果你想知道在一个月明之夜与爱人手牵手散步是什么感觉，你得出门去寻找一个伴侣。想知道在一个月明之夜与爱人手牵手散步是什么感觉。你得出门去寻找一个伴侣。
But something in our culture has changed. As we sit on the couch and eat takeout, we watch kitchen virtuosos whip up gourmet meals from scratch. Turn it over, look at the color. And it just makes the house smell like home to me. And then we watch other people eat meals. So if you were alone on Thanksgiving, I hope you would have your Thanksgiving dinner with me. I mean that literally, there's a popular genre on YouTube.
但我们文化中的某些东西已经改变了。当我们坐在沙发上吃外卖时，我们看着厨房里的能手从零开始做出精美的美食。把它翻过来，看看颜色。这让我觉得房子闻起来像个家。然后我们看着别人吃饭。所以如果你在感恩节独自一人，我希望你能和我一起吃感恩节晚餐。我是字面意思，YouTube上有一个很受欢迎的流派。
Okay, my mouth's seriously celebrating right now. Well, you just watch other people, binge eat. Okay, I'm starving. I'm starving. There's a lot here. Oh my God. It has never been so easy to bring the world into our living rooms and kitchens and bedrooms.
好吧，我的嘴现在真的在狂欢。好吧，你只是看着别人，暴饮暴食。好吧，我快饿死了。我快饿死了。这里有很多东西。哦天哪。把世界带进我们的客厅、厨房和卧室，从来没有这么容易过。
And the world that enters our lives has never looked better. You can get the ocean without the seaweed and sunsets without clouds. You can scale a rock face without the fear of a fall. You can experience love. Rebecca, Joe Kufren, my Becca, will you marry me? Without the risk of rejection. The smiles are bigger.
而且进入我们生活的这个世界也从来没有这么美好过。你可以拥有没有海草的海洋，没有云彩的日落。你可以攀登岩壁而不必害怕坠落。你可以体验爱情。丽贝卡，乔·库夫伦，我的丽贝卡，你愿意嫁给我吗？而没有被拒绝的风险。笑容更大了。
The emotions are more spectacular. What? I will be... The risks and rewards seem greater, The miles are bigger. The emotions are more spectacular. One, two, three. The risks and rewards seem greater, even though neither really belonged to us. We're in games! We just got a game! These other lives we've come to inhabit can seem more beautiful, more exciting, more satisfying than anything in our actual lives.
情绪更加震撼。什么？我会……风险和回报似乎更大，里程更大。情绪更加震撼。一，二，三。风险和回报似乎更大，尽管这两者其实都不属于我们。我们在游戏中！我们刚刚得到了一个游戏！我们开始栖息的这些其他生活，似乎比我们现实生活中的任何事情都更美丽、更令人兴奋、更令人满足。
They come in multiple camera angles with all the boring parts spliced out and all the recipe ingredients pre-chopped in those little prep bowls. I definitely vicariously live through cooking shows. I catch myself spending hours a week watching climbing videos on Instagram. I've even built my own climbing wall but I don't use it. Why? My husband watches a Navy SEAL talk about discipline and hard work while eating cereal at 11 p.m. Today, we're thinking about how many of us are outsourcing our lives to virtual alter regas. We'll hear stories from listeners about the lure of losing ourselves in the worlds of other people. And we ask,
它们以多个摄像机角度呈现，所有无聊的部分都被剪掉了，所有的食谱配料都在那些小备料碗里预先切好了。我绝对是通过烹饪节目过着间接的生活。我发现自己每周花几个小时在Instagram上观看攀岩视频。我甚至自己建了一面攀岩墙，但我不用它。为什么？我丈夫在晚上11点一边吃麦片，一边看着海豹突击队队员谈论纪律和努力工作。今天，我们在思考我们当中有多少人将自己的生活外包给了虚拟的另一个我。我们将听到听众讲述迷失在别人世界里的诱惑的故事。我们禁不住要问，
what happens when we do this, when we live through the people on our screens and in our headphones? The delights and the dangers of living vicariously this week on Hidden Brain. In most areas of his life, John Sharp is a doer, not a watcher. He is good with his hands and worked for a while as a carpenter's assistant. So a few years ago, when he bought his first house, he made sure to get one with a garage so he could build a wood shop. It's tiny but he's proud of it. Right now I've got a nice 14-inch bandsaw, a three-horsepower cabinet saw, I've got some festival products which are very high end. One of his most important tools though is YouTube. He teaches himself everything he needs to know by watching instructional videos.
当我们这样做时会发生什么，当我们通过屏幕上和耳机里的人生活时？间接生活的乐趣与危险，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在生活的多数领域里，约翰·夏普（John Sharp）是一个行动者，而不是旁观者。他心灵手巧，曾做过一段时间的木工助理。所以几年前，当他买下他的第一栋房子时，他确保买了一间带车库的房子，这样他就可以建造一个木工坊。它很小，但他为此感到自豪。现在我有一个很好的14英寸带锯，一台三马力机柜锯，我有一些非常高端的费斯托（Festool）产品。然而，他最重要的工具之一是YouTube。他通过观看教学视频自学所需的一切。
It's his first stop for most of his projects, like the crib he just built for his new bond daughter, and the desk he's been working on for his wife. And I've got, you know, probably three or four projects that are just halfway complete or in the queue, if you will. But John's a sixth grade teacher, and he's usually worn out by the end of the day. And so he's been finding himself spending less time in his shop and more time on his couch just watching those how-to videos. And what I do is I usually use it as a to decompress after work.
这是他大多数项目的第一站，比如他刚为新出生的女儿做的小床，以及他一直在为妻子制作的书桌。你知道，我有三四个项目才刚完成了一半，或者说在排队等候，如果你愿意这么说的话。但约翰是一名六年级老师，他通常在一天结束时精疲力竭。因此，他发现自己花在工坊里的时间变少了，花在沙发上观看那些如何做视频的时间变多了。我通常用它来作为下班后的放松。
So I go home, open up YouTube, you know, like the other night I was watching at how to build a barn door, because I'm also building one in my house, and I thought, oh, I just wanna get different ideas. What's going on, everybody? I'm Bruce Ulrich, welcome back. In today's video, I'm gonna show you. And it just becomes like this vortex where I'm just like, oh, there's one cool one.
所以回家后，打开YouTube，你知道的，就像前几天我在看如何制作一扇谷仓门，因为我家里也正在做一扇，我想，哦，我只是想获得不同的灵感。大家好，我是布鲁斯·乌尔里希，欢迎回来。在今天的视频中，我将向大家展示。它就像一个漩涡，让我想，哦，这个很酷。
I love sliding doors. I think it's cool. And oh, look, there's a different one. I'll watch that one. I built this out of an embrojemental slab. It's not actually one big slug. And then, you know, it seems like 30 to 45 minutes of pass while I watch videos on, you know, people fixing car engines. Super clean your engine bay. So clean that you'll be able to eat off
我喜欢推拉门。我觉得这很酷。哦，看，还有一个不同的。我要看那个。我是用一块原木板做的。其实不是一整块大料。然后，你知道的，30到45分钟就这样过去了，我一直在看别人修汽车引擎的视频。超级清洁你的引擎舱。干净到你可以在上面吃饭。
or how to build decks. So we're gonna start out by putting the ledger on the house or how to renovate houses. Hey guys, this is my kitchen And it's just non-stop. It's just I mean I could be on there hours and hours and just I mean on a weekday I'll usually watch on average two hours, but on a weekend if I don't have a lot going on You know, I will watch four to five hours easily in a day At first it's entertaining. There's definitely a pleasure aspect of it at the beginning. But after 45 minutes or so, that feeling of enjoyment goes away.
或者如何建造露台。所以我们将从在房子上安装垫木开始，或者如何翻新房屋。嘿，伙计们，这是我的厨房。这简直没完没了。我的意思是，我可以在上面呆上好几个小时，我的意思是，在工作日我通常平均看两个小时，但如果在周末我没有太多事情要做，你知道的，我一天里轻松就能看四到五个小时。起初这很有趣。一开始肯定有娱乐的成分。但在大约45分钟后，那种享受的感觉就消失了。
And it's just like guilt, then it totally switches from pleasure to, you know, oh, you lazy ass, why are you sitting here when you could be out there? And as he sits there there watching instead of doing, he feels like he's losing something. When I watch the video, what I think I'm losing is I'm losing the ability to gain the skill. I think I'm tricking my mind to think that, you know, oh, I'm getting that skill, I watch the video,
剩下的只有内疚，然后完全从快乐转变为，你知道的，哦，你这个懒骨头，当你可以出去的时候，你为什么坐在这里？当他坐在那里观看而不是行动时，他觉得自己正在失去一些东西。当我观看视频时，我认为我正在失去的是我失去获得这项技能的能力。我认为我在欺骗我的大脑，认为，哦，我正在掌握那个技能，我看了视频，
I know how to do it. In reality, that's not true. I can watch a 20 minute video and that person has shown in 20 minutes what probably has taken them days to do, and I am losing the time and the skill of practice for myself. So instead of going into my shop and practicing the skill that I've seen or this new technique that I'm interested in, I'll just watch another video. Watching experts do expert things is not a new phenomenon. In the 1700 in his autobiography, it has ever since been a pleasure to see good workmen handle their tools.
我知道该怎么做。现实并非如此。我可以看一个20分钟的视频，那个人在20分钟里展示的可能是他们花了几天时间才做完的事情，而我正在失去我自己的时间和练习技能的机会。因此，我没有去我的工坊练习我所看到的技能或我感兴趣的新技术，而是去看另一个视频。看专家做专家做的事并不是什么新现象。在1700年他的自传中，看到优秀的工匠摆弄他们的工具一直是一种乐趣。
In 19th century England, spectators watched surgeons dissect corpses, sometimes accompanied by the music of a flute. ["Must be a a little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little And nearly 3,000 years ago, crowds gathered in a stadium to watch people run, jump, and perform other athletic feats in the ancient Olympic games.
在19世纪的英国，旁观者观看外科医生解剖尸体，有时还伴随着长笛音乐。[“一定是一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点一点点月亮闪烁。不仅如此，近三千年前，古希腊奥运会上，人群聚集在体育场里观看人们跑步、跳跃以及进行其他运动绝技。
What's different today is that our access to experts has exploded. Never before in human history has it been possible to see so many people display their talents. And never before in human history have so many things counted as talents. I can't remember when I started watching YouTube videos. I think it really started to get popular back when I was in middle school or high school. This is Irene Yeh, a software engineer in Santa Monica, California. Irene is busy.
今天与过去不同的是，我们接触专家的渠道呈爆炸式增长。人类历史上从未有过如此多的人展示他们的才华。人类历史上也从未有过如此多的事情被视为才华。我不记得我是什么时候开始看YouTube视频的。我想它真正开始流行是在我上初中或高中时。这是艾琳·叶（Irene Yeh），加利福尼亚州圣莫尼卡的软件工程师。艾琳很忙。
She can easily be at work for 10 hours a day. In the morning she wakes up, grabs something quick for breakfast, and she's out the door in about 40 minutes. At night she sometimes doesn't get home until 10. After she's taken a quick shower and had her dinner delivered, she often wanders over to YouTube and pulls up a video of someone else's bedtime routine.
她一天工作10小时是很轻松的事。早上她醒来，匆忙抓点早餐当饭，大约40分钟后就出门了。晚上她有时到10点才回家。在洗了个快澡并点了外卖晚餐后，她经常闲逛到YouTube上，调出一个别人睡前日常的视频。
And for a while, she enters an alternate reality. Hey guys, so for today's video, I'm gonna be showing you my nighttime routine to de-stress and relax after a long day at work. I usually stop. These videos are people, mostly girls, take of themselves, showing how they come home from work. So when I come home, the very first thing that I do
有一段时间，她进入了一个交替的现实。嘿，伙计们，所以今天的视频中，我将向大家展示我在工作了漫长的一天后减压和放松的夜间日常。我通常会停下来。这些视频是人们（主要是女孩）自己拍摄的，展示他们如何下班回家。所以当我回家时，我做的第一件事
is I take off my outside shoes and I put on my house shoes. They make dinner and I always like to have some sort of high protein, vegan option mixed with a They unwind and go to bed. I fluff my pillows, I pull back the sheets, not sleeping with the comforter. So I just slept with them. And I usually get a really good night's sleep after doing this routine. I genuinely sleep like a baby. So I hope that you guys, I...
就是脱掉外面的鞋子，换上家居鞋。他们做晚餐，我总是喜欢把某种高蛋白、纯素的选择混合在一个。他们放松并上床睡觉。我拍松枕头，拉开床单，不盖羽绒被睡觉。所以我只是和它们一起睡觉。完成这套日常后，我通常能睡个好觉。我真的像婴儿一样熟睡。所以我希望你们，我……
Irene suspects these women don't actually live like this. But she doesn't mind the Artifice. She herself doesn't have the bandwidth right now to make side dishes or exfoliate. She'd rather watch someone else do those things and for a few minutes escape into another person's life. It's cheaper, it's simpler, and the emotional results close enough. Honestly watching these people do all the hard work and make up their perfect license, it's like a lot easier for me to get a taste of what this type of life could be,
艾琳怀疑这些女性实际上并没有这样生活。但她并不介意这种虚假。她自己目前没有足够的精力来做配菜或去角质。她宁愿看别人做这些事，并在几分钟内逃进另一个人的生活。这更便宜、更简单，而且情感上的结果也足够接近。老实说，看着这些人做完所有的苦活并编造出他们完美的生活，这让我更容易品尝到这种生活可能会是什么样子，
while I lounge in my amapid and eating my Chinese takeout. in my amapered and eating my Chinese takeout. Living vicariously makes us feel like we have the things we want, even when we can't have them. It's a substitute for the real lives we lead and for the things we lack in those lives. Living through others also fills even deeper needs. It can fill the holes in our psychological lives and serve as a self-esteem pick me up. A listener from Florida shared a story with us along these lines. She requested that we only use her first name in order to protect her privacy. Okay, I'm Natalie. I live in Miami. Right now I'm working in human resources.
而我则懒洋洋地躺在我的amapid（应为armchair或类似词，此处译为沙发椅/躺椅的语境）上吃着中式外卖。在我的amapid（此处维持语境）上吃着中式外卖。间接生活让我们觉得自己拥有了想要的东西，即使我们无法拥有它们。它是我们过着的真实生活以及我们在这些生活中所缺乏的东西的替代品。通过他人生活也满足了更深层次的需求。它能填补我们心理生活中的空白，并作为一种提升自尊的兴奋剂。来自佛罗里达州的一位听众与我们分享了这方面的一个故事。为了保护隐私，她要求我们只使用她的名字。好吧，我是娜塔莉。我住在迈阿密。现在我在人力资源部门工作。
Natalie is 23 years old and says she was always on the quiet side. She had a rough time in high school and withdrew into herself. High school and I guess all of primary school, you know, before I went to college was kind of hard for me. I was very quiet, a little insecure. Natalie felt she was overweight. She got bullied. She was interested in music and singing, but her low self-esteem meant she rarely put herself out there.
娜塔莉23岁，说自己一直是比较安静的那类人。她在高中时过得很艰难，并封闭了自己。高中，我想还有整个小学，你知道的，在我上大学之前对我来说有点难。我很安静，有点不安全感。娜塔莉觉得自己超重了。她被霸凌了。她对音乐和唱歌感兴趣，但她低下的自尊心意味着她很少表现自己。
So, you know, I never really tried to get feedback, because I was afraid of getting a bad response. Her family would sometimes notice her drifting off into her own world. They would always say, not only what are you thinking about because I would just be staring off into space going on little tangents in my mind. One time Natalie was with an aunt on a cruise. She was staring off into the distance, lost her thought for more than an hour. And she finally asked me, what are you thinking about?
所以，你知道的，我从不真正试图获得反馈，因为我害怕得到不好的回应。她的家人有时会注意到她陷入自己的世界。他们总是会说，娜塔莉，你在想什么，因为我只会凝视太空，在脑海中做着各种小跑题。有一次娜塔莉和姑姑一起去游轮旅行。她凝视着远方，走神了一个多小时。她终于问我，你在想什么？
And I was thinking about a TV show that I had been watching, just like imagining myself being on the production set or something like that. Everybody quiet, officer, cut. Why did the others? Over the years, as new forms of technology sprang up around her, Natalie found new solutions to the missing pieces in her life. She takes out her phone and opens Instagram to a photo of a woman with long, brown hair.
我在想我一直在看的一个电视节目，想象自己身处制作片场或类似的地方。大家都安静，警官，卡。为什么其他人？多年来，随着周围涌现出各种新技术，娜塔莉为生活中的缺失部分找到了新的解决方案。她掏出手机，打开Instagram，看到了一张一个留着长棕发的女人的照片。
She has a long sleeve top tucked into some high-waisted shorts. She looks like she's in really, really good shape. Her makeup is perfect. And when I see her outfit, it's beautiful. And I know that I would never even think to put those clothing items together. Like I could never, you know, put an outfit that stylish together. I asked her why she felt that trendy outfits were not for her in real life. I still, you know, feel like that little girl sometimes and I don't want to stand out. I don't want to bring too much attention to myself. Other times, Natalie Thumbs through Pinterest. I have like folders for each of the rooms in my home. It's almost like I can go into my Pinterest bedroom
她穿一件长袖上衣，塞进高腰短裤里。她看起来身材真的非常好。她的妆容很完美。当我看到她的穿搭时，它太美了。我知道我甚至不会想到把这些衣服搭配在一起。就像我永远无法，你知道的，搭配出这么时髦的一套衣服。我问她为什么觉得现实生活中不适合穿这种潮流服装。有时我仍然，你知道的，觉得自己像个小女孩，我不想引人注目。我不想给自己带来太多注意。其他时候，娜塔莉浏览着Pinterest。我家里每个房间都有文件夹。这几乎就像我可以进入我的Pinterest卧室
and see my beautiful bed and the sheets are very expensive. So I have one called my first home. I have one called beauty. I have one for my wedding that's coming up. I have one for do-it-yourself projects, which I have never attempted. Natalie drives more than an hour to work each way five days a week. Along the way she listens to music.
看到我美丽的床，床单非常昂贵。所以我有一个文件夹叫我的第一个家。我有一个叫美丽。我有一个为即将到来的婚礼准备的。我有一个为自己动手项目准备的，但我从未尝试过。娜塔莉每周有五天单程开车一个多小时去上班。一路上她听着音乐。
Actually, listening doesn't quite describe what she does. And when I listen to music I'm always the musician. Like I'll be singing in my head. And I'll even like start the song over if I missed my favorite part because I want to see myself singing the best part of the song. So I'll make fun of myself that I can listen to the same song 50 times just to get it right in my fake performance. Give me an example of the kind of song that's happened the last time too.
其实，听并不能准确描述她的所作所为。当我听音乐时，我总是音乐家。就像我在脑海里唱歌一样。如果我错过了最喜欢的部分，我甚至会把歌曲重新开始，因为我想看到自己唱出歌曲最精彩的部分。所以我常常自嘲，我可以把同一首歌听50遍，只为了在我的假表演中把它唱对。给我举一个上次也发生过的那种歌的例子。
Oh my god. Tiny dancer by Elton John this morning. Natalie imagines herself singing and playing the piano. I'm a great musician in my head. I play every instrument. I can sing any song. And there's something else. This is so embarrassing, but I want somebody else to be watching me. Like, I'll kind of be performing it in my head in front of an audience. I'm an amazing man.
哦天哪。今天早上的埃尔顿·约翰的《蒂姆丹瑟》（Tiny Dancer）。娜塔莉想象自己唱歌并弹钢琴。我在脑海里是个伟大的音乐家。我演奏每一种乐器。我能唱任何歌。还有一件事。这太尴尬了，但我希望有人在看着我。就像，我会在观众面前在脑海里表演它。我是一个了不起的人。
In the audience, I see my parent. I'll think, okay, well, I want my best friend there, so then I'll focus on what my best friend would look like in the audience watching on the highway. Of course, you wouldn't be able to spot Natalie the magnetic performer if you passed Natalie the driver on the highway. No, if you looked at me, I would look completely normal. Ten and two on the steering wheel. She scrolls to her phone and pulls up a duet,
在观众席中，我看到了我的父母。我会想，好吧，我希望我最好的朋友在那里，然后我会专注于我最好的朋友在高速公路旁观看的观众席中会是什么样子。当然，如果你在高速公路上经过驾驶汽车的娜塔莉，你是认不出这位充满磁性的表演者的。不，如果你看着我，我会看起来完全正常。双手紧握方向盘的十点和两点钟方向。她滚动手机，调出一个二重唱，
featuring Bradley Cooper and Lady Gaga. Are you tired trying to fill that void? Or do you need more? I'm falling And all the good times I find myself falling For change And all the bad times I hear myself I'm on the deep end, what just I can't hit the nose that she's hitting right now.
由布莱德利·库珀和Lady Gaga演唱。你厌倦了试图填补那个空虚吗？还是你需要更多？我正在下坠，在所有美好的时光里，我发现自己为了改变而下坠，在所有糟糕的时光里，我听到自己……我在深渊里，刚刚发生了什么？我唱不出她现在正在唱的那个高音。
I asked Natalie what she thought these daydreams were doing for her. It almost feels like it's filling a void that I haven't been able to fill ever since in high school. That was the closest I ever came to being a musician. Natalie's fiancé bought her a guitar after she told him her dream of being a performer. The instrument has mostly sat unused. The daydream versions, the ones on her phone, those versions are so much better. Watching or hearing someone else do things makes Natalie feel good, but only for a moment. Yeah, well, I mean, when you're watching them do it on TV, it just, it looks so easy and nobody
我问娜塔莉，她觉得这些白日梦对她有什么帮助。这感觉就像是在填补高中以来我一直无法填补的空缺。那是我离成为音乐家最近的一次。娜塔莉的未婚夫在她表达了成为表演者的梦想后给她买了一把吉他。这把乐器大部分时间都闲置着。白日梦版本，手机里的那些版本，那些版本要好得多。看别人或听别人做事会让娜塔莉感觉很好，但只是一会儿。是的，我的意思是，当你在电视上看着他们做这件事时，它看起来太简单了，而且没有人
talks about how hard it is. And, you know, I think that's also why it makes people feel so bad about themselves because, you know, this person on TV, it's so easy for them. Why is it so hard for me to get these things done? What's wrong with me? Many of us have experienced what Natalie is feeling, a mix of emotions as we watch others perform difficult tasks with ease. We find it inspiring and we find it deflating. Coming up, the quirk in our heads that makes watching others so compelling. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
谈论它有多难。而且，你知道，我认为这也是人们对自己的感觉很糟糕的原因，因为，你知道，电视上的这个人，这对他们来说太容易了。为什么我把这些事情做好这么难？我怎么了？我们许多人都经历过娜塔莉的感受，当我们看着别人轻而易举地完成困难任务时，心中交织着各种情绪。我们觉得它鼓舞人心，也觉得它令人泄气。接下来，我们头脑中的那个怪癖让观看别人变得如此引人入胜。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Hello, I'm Bob Ross. If this is your first time with us, let me extend a personal invitation if you'd drag out your little paint brushes and some paints and paint along with us each show. Tell you what, let's get right to it. If you happen to watch public television in the 80s and 90s, you may have come across the painter, Bob Ross. And let that knife just float. Let it have come across the painter, Bob Ross. And let that knife just float, let it float right down the side of the mountain. Think about where light would strike.
你好，我是鲍勃·罗斯（Bob Ross）。如果这是你第一次和我们在一起，让我发出一个个人的邀请，如果你能拿出你的小画笔和一些颜料，在每个节目中和我们一起画画。跟你说吧，让我们直接开始吧。如果你在80和90年代看过公共电视，你可能遇到过画家鲍勃·罗斯。让那把刀顺势飘过去。让它遇到过画家鲍勃·罗斯。让那把刀顺势飘过去，让它顺着山坡飘下去。想想光会打在哪里。
With his gentle voice, kind eyes, and halo of brown hair, he made you feel, soon, got to make his little noises or it doesn't work right. That you could absolutely learn, how to paint like a master. Just pull. See, they're not easy that is, so take a little blue, a little tiny bit of blue. Edelbrayan knows why so many Americans fell in love with Bob Ross, and why they felt after watching him,
伴随着他温柔的声音、慈祥的眼神和一头棕色的光环头发，他让你觉得，一会儿，必须发出他的小声音，否则效果不对。你绝对可以学会，如何像大师一样画画。只要拉。看，它们并不容易，所以取一点蓝色，一小点蓝色。埃德·布莱扬（Ed O'Brien，注：此处指埃德·奥布莱恩/Ed O'Brien，人名）知道为什么那么多美国人爱上了鲍勃·罗斯，以及为什么他们在看完他之后感到，
just let your imagination take it anywhere you want to go. That they could be painters too. You could also hear in that clip just the warmth and encouragement. I really, you really are kind of inspired to jump right in and try yourself. It is a behavioral scientist at the University of Chicago's Bootschool of Business. Along with colleague Michael Cardis, he studies mental simulation. What we think a new experience will feel like. One thing we find is that, you know, instructional videos, other videos you can pull up on YouTube.
只要让你的想象力带它去你想去的任何地方。他们也可以成为画家。你也可以从那个片段中听到温暖和鼓励。我真的，你真的有点受到启发，想要马上跳进去自己尝试一下。他是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的行为科学家。他和同事迈克尔·卡迪斯（Michael Kardas）一起研究心理模拟。我们认为一次新体验会是什么感觉。我们发现的一件事是，你知道，教学视频，你可以从YouTube上调出的其他视频。
They teach you something, so they tell you objective details about that experience. But viewers come away thinking that those things have taught them everything. And that discrepancy is at the core of what we're interested in here. Did you and Michael ever experience this yourselves? For sure, I mean, you know, as a consumer myself, you know, at the sports end of things, interested in here. Did you and Michael ever experience this yourselves? For sure, I mean, as a consumer myself, at the sports end of things, you can catch yourself screaming at the TV, why did the quarterback not make that throw?
它们教给你一些东西，所以它们告诉你关于那体验的客观细节。但观众离开时却认为这些东西已经教会了他们一切。这种差异正是我们这里感兴趣的核心。你和迈克尔有没有自己经历过这个？当然，我的意思是，你知道的，作为我自己一个消费者，你知道的，在体育方面，对这里感兴趣。你和迈克尔有没有自己经历过这个？当然，我的意思是，作为一个消费者，在体育方面，你会发现自己在对电视大喊大叫，为什么四分卫不那样传球？
Kind of catching myself wondering, it's probably a lot harder in real life than I think about sitting on this couch. So certainly, experiences like that. And also for my professional life, you know, when I started as a professor here a few years ago, one major part of the job is teaching. And one thing we do here at the University of Chicago is have new professors sit in on a class. So I spent a whole quarter watching someone else teach before I then
有点发现自己在想，在现实生活中可能比我坐在沙发上想的要难得多。所以当然，有这样的经历。而且对于我的职业生活，你知道的，几年前我刚开始在这里担任教授时，工作的一个主要部分就是教学。我们在芝加哥大学做的一件事就是让新教授旁听一门课。所以我花了整整一个季度的时间看别人教书，然后我才
the next quarter jumped in and taught. And that was also an interesting learning experience for me. After 10 weeks of watching someone, you kind of feel pretty confident. I've invested a lot of time and effort into this. And then the next quarter rolls around and I'm the one in the suit now standing in front of the room and all the eyes are on me.
在接下来的一个季度跳进去教书。对我来说这也是一次有趣的求知经历。在观察了某人10 weeks（周）后，你会有相当自信的感觉。我在这上面投入了大量的时间和精力。然后下一个季度到了，现在我是那个穿西装站在房间前面、所有目光都集中在我身上的人。
And I quickly realized it's a lot easier to watch somebody do something than it is to actually do it yourself. So also in the professional world, kind of learning through getting a taste of experience, you often realize how much harder things are in practice. It's interesting because as you talk, I'm reminded of the very common experience that many of us have watching people who are very good at doing things, which is they do make it
我很快意识到，看别人做一件事比自己真正去做要容易得多。所以在职业世界中，通过品味经验来学习，你经常会发现在实践中事情要困难得多。这很有趣，因为当你说话时，让我想起了我们许多人都有过的非常普遍的经历，即观看那些擅长做事的人，那就是他们确实做到了
look easy. You watch a chef chopping vegetables or you watch a musician playing the piano and people who've been doing things for a long time, there is not just a skill and an excellence in what they do, but there's an effortlessness in what they do. And you pick up on that and you say, all I have to do is sit before the piano and let my fingers relax and surely I can play Mozart too. I find that very interesting. This idea that making it look easy, we might have a hard time appreciating expertise. We can have underappreciate what other people are performing, what other experts are doing
看起来很简单。你看着厨师切菜，或者看着音乐家弹钢琴，那些长期做这些事情的人，他们的所作所为不仅有一种技能和卓越，而且有一种毫不费力的感觉。你注意到了这一点，然后你说，我所要做的就是坐在钢琴前，让我的手指放松，我肯定也能弹奏莫扎特。我觉得这非常有趣。这种认为它看起来很简单、我们可能很难欣赏专业知识的想法。我们可能会低估其他人正在表演的东西，其他专家正在做的事情
for us, technicians that fix things for us, athletes that perform for us. The best of them, ironically, make it seem like it's the easiest possible performance from an observer's perspective. So I am really interested in that discrepancy. Do we kind of struggle to fully appreciate the talents of others? Ed wanted to test the hypothesis that watching experts perform a skill, watching them over and over again, improves people's confidence, but not their ability. So he came up with some clever experiments. In one of them, he had 400 volunteers watch an instructional video
为我们做的事，为我们修东西的技术人员，为我们表演的运动员。讽刺的是，他们当中最好的人让它从观察者的角度看起来像是最简单的表演。所以我真的对这种差异很感兴趣。我们是否在某种程度上难以完全欣赏他安人的才华？埃德想测试这样一个假设：观看专家展示一项技能，一遍又一遍地观看他们，可以提高人们的自信心，而不是他们的能力。所以他想出了一些聪明的实验。其中一个实验中，他让400名志愿者观看教学视频
to learn how to do the tablecloth trick. Three, two, one, heart. And the crowd goes wild! Thank you! It's that magic trick where you pull a tablecloth out from underplates and silverware without disturbing anything on the table. Ed had lots of videos to choose from on YouTube. I've got both plates, cups and saucers, do you like a cup of coffee? Well, thank you.
学习如何做桌布魔术。三，二，一，心。人群疯狂了！谢谢！这是一个魔术，你把桌布从盘子和银器下面抽出来，而不会打扰桌子上的任何东西。埃德有许多视频可以从YouTube上选择。我有盘子、杯子和茶托，你想喝杯咖啡吗？好的，谢谢。
Many videos talk you through the trick, step by step. Step 5. Pull the cloths straight down toward the ground. Pull quickly and with confidence, so that the tablecloth slides out from under the dishes and cups. Ed wanted to test the effects of learning through watching. So he found a nearly silent video where a bearded science teacher demonstrates the magic trick for students.
许多视频一步一步地向你讲解魔术。步骤5。把桌布笔直往下拉向地面。快速且自信地拉动，以便桌布从盘子和杯子下面滑出。埃德想测试通过观看学习的效果。因此，他找到了一段近乎无声的视频，视频中一位留着大胡子的科学老师向学生演示了这个魔术。
The teacher's hands bob up and down as he holds the ends of a tablecloth, and he concentrates on three bowls and some silverware. Then he pulls the tablecloth, the dishes and silverware barely move. It's all over in less than 15 seconds. Nothing to it, right? I'm interested in that video because on the surface it's such a hard task. Anybody should recognize that this is a really complicated thing to pull off. It doesn't matter if I just watched a video 20 times. This is really, really hard if I've never tried it before.
老师的手上下晃动，手里拿着桌布的两端，他专注于三个碗和一些银器。然后他拉动桌布，盘子和银器几乎没有动。这一切在不到15秒内就结束了。没什么大不了的，对吧？我对那个视频很感兴趣，因为表面上这是一个如此艰巨的任务。任何人都能认出这是一件非常复杂的事情。即使我刚刚看了20遍视频也没有用。如果我以前从未尝试过，这真的、真的很难。
We thought this was going to be a conservative test of the hypothesis that, of course, merely watching a video shouldn't make me better off. This is something that I'm going to have to practice a bunch of times. And yet we find that if you watch this video 20 times, for example, and we specifically ask you, imagine you jump in right now with no other practice than what you've just had, how well would you do on your very first attempt? You jump in and try to pull the tablecloth out. And if you've watched a bunch of times, you think you could pull it off, which I find rather surprising because of how obviously complicated that skill is. I would find it very unlikely that participants can pull it off merely from watching the video many times.
我们认为这将是对这一假设的保守测试，即仅仅观看视频当然不应该让我变得更好。这是我必须练习很多次的事情。然而我们发现，如果你把这个视频看上20遍，例如，并且我们明确问你，想象你现在就跳进去，除了刚刚的经验外没有其他练习，你在第一次尝试时会表现得怎么样？你跳进去并试图把桌布抽出来。如果你看了很多遍，你认为你能成功，我觉得这相当令人惊讶，因为这个技能显然很复杂。我认为参与者仅仅通过多次观看视频就能成功拉出桌布是非常不可能的。
And you found in fact that there was in some way sort of a dose effect relationship, the more times people watch the video, the more they watched it, the more they felt they could do it themselves. Exactly. And what's especially interesting there is we compared that exposure to other kinds of training you could do. So we had people watching videos and the more that they watched videos, the more confident they became. But this wasn't true for other kinds of training.
事实上，你发现某种程度上存在一种剂量效应关系，人们看视频的次数越多，看的次数越多，他们就越觉得自己能行。完全正确。特别有趣的是，我们将这种接触与其他你可以做的训练进行了比较。我们让人们观看视频，他们看的视频越多，他们就越自信。但这对于其他类型的训练并不适用。
So if we had people spend more time just thinking about the trick or spend more time reflecting on the trick or spending more time reading written instructions about how to about the trick or spend more time reflecting on the trick or spending more time reading written instructions about how to do the trick, more time didn't lead people to be more confident. So there seems to be something special about having lots of practice with videos above and beyond other kinds of practice. In other words to summarize what you were saying, reading about the skill does not seem to communicate the same transfer of expertise than merely watching someone perform the skill.
因此，如果我们让人们花更多时间思考这个魔术，或者花更多时间反思这个魔术，或者花更多时间阅读关于如何做这个魔术的书面说明，花更多时间并没有让人们更有自信。因此，除了其他类型的练习之外，与视频有大量练习似乎有一些特殊之处。换句话说，总结你刚才所说的话，阅读这项技能似乎并没有像仅仅观看某人展示这项技能那样传达同等程度的专业知识转移。
Exactly. Watching seems intimately connected to our perceptions that we're learning. Now, now please tell me that with the tablecloth experiment you actually had beginner stand before tablecloth and actually yank the tablecloth out. Please tell me that actually did happen. I am very regrettably informing you that we did not run that condition, but I think I will after this discussion. You'd have to invest a fair amount in new China, I'm guessing. We would, we would.
完全正确。观看似乎与我们正在学习的感知息息相关。现在，现在请告诉我，在桌布实验中，你真的让初学者站在桌布前，并真正把桌布猛拉出来了。请告诉我这真的发生了。我非常遗憾地通知大家，我们没有进行那个条件测试，但我想讨论完这个后我会做的。我猜你必须在新的中国瓷器上投资相当大的一笔钱。我们会，我们会。
I mean, we did try to bottle this in a more fun way, so not exactly with the dishes, but we have this moonwalk experiment. And slide the left leg back and then switch. And so this is the instructional video that we had participants watch a clip of that was supposedly going to try to train them. This is exactly how you do the moonwalk. You're going to slide the left leg back and you're going to switch weights.
我的意思是，我们确实试图以一种更有趣的方式来包装它，所以不完全是用盘子，但我们有这个太空步（moonwalk）实验。把左腿向后滑动然后切换。这就是我们让参与者观看的一段剪辑中的教学视频，据说它将试图训练他们。这就是你做太空步的确切方法。你要把左腿向后滑动，你要切换重心。
So the right leg goes down, you push the left back. When you're pushing the left leg back, keep it flat on the ground. Switch, switch, switch. All right guys, here we go. One music. Five, six, five, six, seven, go. One, two, three, four. But again, the key thing that we're interested in is, you know, once you're actually trying those
所以右腿下降，你把左腿向后推。当你把左腿向后推时，让它平贴在地面上。切换，切换，切换。好了，伙计们，我们开始吧。音乐。五，六，五，六，七，走。一，二，三，四。但再次强调，我们感兴趣的关键事情是，你知道，一旦你真正尝试了那些
steps, it turns out there's also some internal reactions and feelings and emotions and nerves that make it harder than it seems. So in this study what we did was we took this same exact instructional video and participants either watched it once or watched it 20 times. So again, this is our key manipulation here, getting people lots of exposure to video watching, how does that affect their perceptions of learning, and how does that affect their actual learning. So we told them to imagine that there was a panel of judges who would then watch them perform the moonwalk once across the screen, and they were going to judge how well they performed the moonwalk.
步骤，事实证明，也有一些内在的反应、感觉、情绪和紧张，使它比看起来更难。所以在这次研究中，我们做的是使用完全相同的教学视频，让参与者要么看一次，要么看20次。所以再次强调，这是我们的关键操作，让人们大量接触视频观看，这如何影响他们的学习感知，以及这如何影响他们的实际学习。因此我们告诉他们想象有一个评审团，他们会看着他们完成一次跨屏的太空步，他们将评判他们太空步表演得有多好。
And we asked them to predict, what do you think, what score do you think you're going to get based on your performance? Then what we did was set up a video camera and participants actually then made an attempt at the Moonwalk. These are very, very fun videos to watch. We have a whole battery of these things in our research library. And truth be told, we showed them to a panel of judges. So the judges had no idea whether this performer had watched the video once or watched the video 20 times. In fact, both sets of participants, whether you watched once or 20 times, didn't do very well.
然后我们要求他们预测，你认为根据你的表现你会得到什么分数。然后我们做的是架起一台摄像机，参与者随后真正尝试了太空步。这些是非常非常有趣的视频。我们的研究库里有一整套这些东西。说实话，我们把它们展示给了一个评审团。所以评委根本不知道这个表演者是看了一次视频还是看20次视频。事实上，这两组参与者，无论你看了一次还是20次，都表现得不是很好。
But again, the key insight here, if you watched 20 times, you thought you were going to kind of win that performance. When, in fact, you performed no better than other participants. This is what we are doing right now. I have no idea how to do that. That's what I was going to do. God, awful. I can't find out. Of course. Of course.
但再次强调，这里的关键见解是，如果你看了20次，你以为你会赢得那场表演。而事实上，你的表现并不比其他参与者好。这就是我们现在正在做的。我不知道怎么做。那就是我要做的。上帝，太糟糕了。我找不出来。当然。当然。
So these are our participants actually trying their moonwalk attempts. And it's great in some of these videos, as you can hear, are kind of verbalizing the difficulties of doing this task. They jump in and they start to try to emulate what they saw in that video, move the right foot back, move the left foot forward, and it turns out they're literally verbalizing how difficult it is.
所以这些是我们的参与者实际尝试太空步的画面。很棒的是在其中一些视频中，正如你所听到的，他们用言语表达了完成这项任务的困难。他们跳进去，开始试图效仿他们在视频中看到的东西，把右脚向后移，把左脚向前移，结果他们字面意义上用言语表达了它是多么困难。
Good. I don't know if I'm doing it, but this is better than you go get for me today. And again, what's especially interesting for us is some of them told us before they made that attempt they're really going to do it well. They're going to nail this attempt. And only in the act of trying to realize oh I guess I didn't learn nearly as much as I thought just from watching that video. When this happens, do you think it changes the way people watch the next videos? Does it possibly once you learn that your overconfidence
好。我不知道我有没有在做，但这比你今天给我做的好。再次强调，对我们来说特别有趣的是，其中一些人在尝试之前告诉我们他们真的会做得很好。他们会搞定这次尝试。只有在尝试的过程中才意识到，哦，我想我仅仅通过看那个视频并没有学到那么多东西。当这种情况发生时，你认为它会改变人们看下一个视频的方式吗？一旦你了解到你的过度自信
was not warranted in one video, do you believe that it's a guard against overconfidence when you watch the next video? I do think it's interesting to consider the possibility that people who jump in and they're really, really confident and it turns out they fail miserably. That's a pretty big gap between who you thought you were and who you find out you are.
在一个视频中是不合理的，它是否可能成为你在观看下一个视频时防范过度自信的护栏？我确实认为考虑这种可能性很有趣，即那些跳进去而且非常非常自信的人，结果发现他们惨败了。这介于你以为你是谁和你发现你是谁之间，差距相当大。
And I suspect that for some participants, that's motivating and they realize, okay, I'm gonna have to invest a lot more practice into this. But I wonder if for a lot of people, that's just demotivating. That the giant gap between perceptions and reality leads them to think, well, I'm not meant for this task after all.
我怀疑对于一些参与者来说，这是有动力作用的，他们意识到，好吧，我必须在这上面投入更多的练习。但我不知道对于很多人来说，这是否只是失去了动力。感知与现实之间的巨大鸿沟让他们觉得，好吧，我毕竟不是干这块料的。
I'm never going to pick up this ability. And so they don't practice again. And that's something I'd love to keep researching. But I do think that's a very real possibility from this effect. How do you balance the idea that in some ways, you know, watching people who are very good at doing something can be a source of inspiration for us. You know, you watch LeBron James playing basketball and you're motivated to go out and try and
我永远也学不会这个技能。于是他们就不再练习了。这是我很想继续研究的课题。但我确实认为，从这种效应来看，这是完全有可能的。你如何平衡这样一种观念：在某些方面，你知道，观看非常擅长某事的人可以成为我们的灵感源泉。你知道，你看着勒布朗·詹姆斯打篮球，你就会有动力走出去尝试
play basketball yourself because what he does is beautiful and it's beautiful to watch. How do you balance that with the fact that when you actually get to the court having watched LeBron James, you might now be more disinclined to pursue basketball as a sport and in fact just retire to watching LeBron James on the couch. That's right. I mean, I think it's really important for learners and people in general as we're trying to pick up new skills to have a longer term mindset in place. So I think if you have that mindset kind of in place,
亲自打篮球，因为他的所作所为很美，而且看他打球也是一种享受。你如何将这一点与这样一个事实进行平衡：当你真正看完勒布朗·詹姆斯的比赛来到球场时，你现在可能会更不愿意将篮球作为一项运动去追求，事实上只是在沙发上退居二线，看勒布朗·詹姆斯打球。没错。我的意思是，我认为对于学习者和一般人来说，在我们试图掌握新技能时，树立长远的心态真的很重要。所以我觉得如果你有那种心态，
it's good to feel inspired by experts that we watch around us. Like I said earlier, it's helpful to kind of inspire action, maybe overconfidence is a good thing in some sense because it gets us off the couch and thinking we can do these things ourselves. I think that is good as long as we realize, right, first time failure doesn't mean something longer term about me. It's the fact that merely watching wasn't enough.
感受到周围专家的启发是件好事。就像我刚才说的，这有助于激发行动，也许在某种意义上过度自信是一件好事，因为它能让我们离开沙发，认为我们自己也能做到这些事情。我认为只要我们意识到这一点，就是好的，初次失败并不意味着关于我的长远问题。这只是因为仅仅观看是不够的。
So now that I'm actually on the playing field, now that I've actually made an attempt and failed, hopefully if people have that long-term mindset in place, they realize that they should stay here and kind of have more real-time experiences that they're going to be in it for the long haul. We only see LeBron James making that awesome dunk in the championship. LeBron for the time! When we think of, maybe I could do that too. Maybe I have that inside of me. When in fact so many other things, years of situations
所以既然我已经上了球场，既然我已经尝试过并且失败了，希望如果人们有那种长远的心态，他们会意识到他们应该留在这里，并进行更多实时体验，他们将为此进行长期投入。我们只看到勒布朗·詹姆斯在总决赛中完成那次精彩的扣篮。勒布朗永远的神！当我们想到，也许我也能做到。也许我的内心也有这种潜力。但事实上，许多其他的事情，多年的情况
and experience went in to allowing Lebron James to show that final product. This Lebron goes one on one, pull the pads, one bullet under, pull the pads. Ed wanted to know if there was a way to keep people from falling prey to the illusion of overconfidence. So before someone tries to replicate a feat they see on YouTube, is there a way to remind them that it's more complicated than they think? To test this, Ed had three groups of volunteers watch a short video of someone juggling with bowling pins and
和经验才造就了勒布朗·詹姆斯的最终表现。这个勒布朗单打，拉开空间，一个漂亮的突破……埃德想知道是否有一种方法可以阻止人们陷入过度自信的错觉。所以在有人试图复制他们在YouTube上看到的绝技之前，有没有办法提醒他们事情比想象的要复杂？为了测试这一点，埃德让三组志愿者观看了一段别人玩保龄球瓶杂耍的短视频，然后
then told everyone that they would be asked to juggle too. He gave each group different kinds of information about juggling, like the weight and dimensions of a bowling pin. But in one group, he had volunteers actually hold a bowling pin for one minute. They didn't juggle it, they just held it. Would giving people this tiny taste of juggling make them better at predicting how difficult the task would be? The answer was yes. All someone needed was that one minute of direct access into the first step of juggling.
告诉每个人他们也会被要求玩杂耍。他向每组提供关于杂耍的不同信息，比如保龄球瓶的重量和尺寸。但在其中一组中，他让志愿者实际握住一个保龄球瓶一分钟。他们没有玩杂耍，只是拿着。给人们这种微小的杂耍体验会让他们更好地预测任务的难度吗？答案是肯定的。每个人只需要那一分钟直接接触杂耍的第一步。
That seems to be enough to remind people, oh yeah, it's not just about holding my hand here and it's not just about this angle, but when I do those things, there's weight involved. There's these physiological reactions that I'm having as I'm performing this trick that will likely make it a little bit harder than I feel it is just from watching. So one big take home from that study is to try to combine instructional video learning with some form of real-world practice. So even if you're just kind of mimicking along at home holding objects, right, it may not be the bowling pin in the video, but holding a weighted object as you're watching this
这似乎足以提醒人们，哦对了，这不仅仅是把手放在这里，也不仅仅是这个角度，当我做这些动作时，是有重量的。我在表演这个把戏时会有这些生理反应，这很可能使它比我仅仅通过观看所感受到的要困难一些。所以这项研究的一个重要结论是，尝试将教学视频学习与某种形式的现实世界实践相结合。因此，即使你只是在家里拿着物品跟着模仿，对吧，可能不是视频中的保龄球瓶，但拿着一个有重量的物体观看这个
thing should presumably make you much better off at appreciating the skills complexity than if you were just merely watching. Why do you think it is that merely sort of getting people in some ways out of their heads and into their bodies seems to provide some kind of buffer or protection against this overconfidence? Mental simulation just isn't built to incorporate kind of physiological reactions in eternal states. Those are states reserved for experience.
东西，据推测，你应该比仅仅观看更能体会到技能的复杂性。为什么你认为仅仅让人们从某种程度上摆脱胡思乱想，进入他们的身体，似乎能提供某种针对这种过度自信的缓冲或保护？心理模拟生来就不是为了结合生理反应和内在状态的。这些状态是留给实际体验的。
So, unfortunately, we spend so much time just in a state of mental simulation. We're constantly just thinking to ourselves, what would happen if I do this, what would happen if I do that, if I move to this city, if I try it out this skill, we're constantly just simulating things. And in those simulations, we lack the bottom-up real-time experience of actually performing, of actually experiencing those events that we can only find when we jump in and try. As Ed's research suggests, watching experts is powerful because we have the sense that some of their expertise rubs off on us.
所以，不幸的是，我们花太多时间处于心理模拟状态中。我们不断地在心里想，如果我这样做会发生什么，如果我那样做会发生什么，如果我搬到这个城市，如果我尝试这项技能会怎样，我们不断地在模拟事情。而在这些模拟中，我们缺乏实际执行、实际体验那些事件的自下而上的实时体验，而这些只有当我们跳进去尝试时才能找到。正如埃德的研究表明的那样，观看专家之所以充满力量，是因为我们觉得他们的一些专业知识传染给了我们。
Watching them creates the illusion that we can be them. To put this another way, our screens offer us a mental shortcut. Without having to learn all the difficult things that experts know, we get the feeling that we can play that beautiful piece of music or build that bondore ourselves. Watching others can also provide us with a safety net. When life gets too hard, our screens can serve up solace. Stay with us. After we posted a call for stories on living through others, a listener named John got in touch to say he wanted to talk. I am 26 years old, I'm living in Cincinnati, Ohio.
看着他们会产生一种我们可以成为他们的错觉。换句话说，我们的屏幕为我们提供了一条心理捷径。无需学习专家所知道的所有难学的东西，我们就会觉得我们可以演奏那首优美的曲子，或者自己建立那种联系。观看他人也可以为我们提供安全网。当生活变得太艰难时，我们的屏幕可以提供慰藉。请继续收听。在我们发出征集关于活在他人的故事的呼吁后，一位名叫约翰的听众联系我们，说他想聊聊。我今年26岁，住在俄亥俄州辛辛那提。
Currently just a utility technician. John didn't say what he wanted to talk about. He asked that we not share his last name. John went to high school in a conservative part of Ohio. For most of those years, he didn't tell anyone that he was gay. Coming out just wasn't a thing you did in high school. He had dates, but not real ones. Mostly, he went out with friends who were girls as a way of blending in. It would just be like meeting girls on dates, just going to the high school prom or home coming.
目前只是一名公用事业技术员。约翰没有说他想聊什么。他要求我们不要透露他的姓氏。约翰在俄亥俄州的一个保守地区读高中。在那大部分时间里，他没有告诉任何人他是同性恋。出柜在高中根本不是一件你会做的事。他有过约会，但不是真正的约会。通常，他和作为朋友的女孩出去，以此作为融入其中的一种方式。这就好像和女孩约会一样，只是去参加高中毕业舞会或返校节。
That was more the main aim. There wasn't any romantic relation other than you were just kind of just friends that liked each other enough. John came out to friends in college. He wanted to date, but it was hard to figure out who was single and who was gay. So he looked for signs. I'll look at something they do. Is their hair a certain way or their fingers a certain way or do they say certain things?
这更像是主要目的。没有什么浪漫关系，除了你们只是那种彼此喜欢到一定程度的朋友。约翰在大学时向朋友出柜。他想约会，但很难弄清楚谁是单身，谁是同性恋。所以他寻找迹象。我会看他们做的一些事情。他们的头发是某个样子的，还是手指是某个样子的，或者他们会说某些话？
John thinks back to a guy in his engineering class sophomore year. He had long hair and red infinity tattoos on his wrists. John thought, hmm, he's cute. But it didn't go anywhere. He could never figure out if the guy was gay and he didn't have the courage to start a conversation. He still finds it hard sorting out who's gay, who's straight, who's single. That's why he turned to Grindr, the dating and hookup app. It removed all the guesswork and at first Grindr was great. His senior year, John found a familiar face on Grindr, someone he'd met his freshman year. John suggested that we call him Ryan. It's a pseudonym. Ryan looked
约翰回想起大二时工程课上的一个男生。他留着长头发，手腕上有红色无限符号纹身。约翰心想，嗯，他很可爱。但这并没有什么进展。他永远也弄不清那个男生是不是同性恋，而他也没有勇气展开对话。他仍然觉得很难分清谁是同性恋，谁是异性恋，谁是单身。这就是为什么他转向Grindr这款约会和约炮软件。它消除了所有的猜测，起初Grindr很棒。在大四的时候，约翰在Grindr上发现了一个熟悉的面孔，那是他在大一认识的人。约翰建议我们叫他瑞恩。这是一个化名。瑞恩看起来
like he spent a lot of time in the gym. He had a great body, blonde hair, and kind blue eyes. For two weeks, they talked through the app about their lives, about music, politics, sexuality. They clicked. You know, we had a lot to talk about, you know, and maybe we'd talk more about it in person. So John asked him, Hey, um, could I get your number? Like your actual real number, not just like, you know, and maybe we'd talk more about it in person. So John asked him, Hey, um, could I get your number, like your actual real number, not just like, you know, your Facebook or your Instagram account? Ryan said yes.
花了很多时间在健身房。他有着健美的身材、金色的头发和温和的蓝色眼睛。两周里，他们通过软件谈论他们的生活、音乐、政治、性取向。他们很合拍。你知道，我们有很多话题可聊，你知道的，也许我们可以当面聊更多。所以约翰问他，嘿，嗯，我能要你的电话号码吗？就像你真正的号码，不只是像，你知道的，也许我们可以当面聊更多。所以约翰问他，嘿，嗯，我能要你的电话号码吗，你真正的号码，不只是像，你知道的，你的Facebook或Instagram账号？瑞恩答应了。
They went to the movies. It was the Martian with Matt Damon. John was nervous, but he took Ryan's hand and kept it there the rest of the movie. At the end, during the credits, Ryan leaned in and gave John a long, confident kiss. They kept kissing as the credits rolled and the music played. The song was love train. John hoped this was the start of something real. Then Halloween came. It's the weekend.
他们去看电影。那是马特·达蒙主演的《火星救援》。约翰很紧张，但他牵起了瑞恩的手，并在接下来的整部电影中一直握着。最后，在演职员表滚动时，瑞恩凑过去，给了约翰一个长久而自信的吻。随着演职员表的滚动和音乐的响起，他们一直在接吻。那首歌是《爱情列车》（Love Train）。约翰希望这是真正恋情的开始。然后万圣节到了。那是周末。
And John finds out that Ryan has made some last-minute plans with a friend to go to Kent, Halloween. This is the annual party scene downtown around Kent State University. John asks, hey, maybe could I come, you know, and he was like, um, sure, you can come. So he makes a costume really fast. I guess I was a mix between kiss and Adam Lambert. Adam Lambert, that pop star who kind of looks like George
约翰发现瑞恩和朋友做了临时计划去肯特参加万圣节活动。这是肯特州立大学市中心每年一度的派对现场。约翰问，嘿，也许我可以去吗，你知道的，然后他说，嗯，当然，你可以去。所以他飞快地制作了一套服装。我想我当时是Kiss乐队和亚当·兰伯特的结合体。亚当·兰伯特，那个看起来有点像乔治
Michael, but with more makeup. And so what I did was I got like a wig with a faux hawk on it and then I put on what white makeup and lipstick. So I guess I looked like a Goth Adam Lambert. That's the best way I can explain this. And he goes out to the bars by himself to wait for Ryan. He starts to drink and he starts to text. When you guys showing up to Kent Halloween, when you guys showing up to Kent Halloween,
迈克尔但妆容更浓的流行歌星。所以我做的是，我弄了一个带有莫西干假发片的发套，然后我涂了白色的妆和口红。所以我想我看起来像个哥特风的亚当·兰伯特。这就是我能解释的最好方式。他独自去酒吧等瑞恩。他开始喝酒，开始发信息。你们什么时候去肯特万圣节？你们什么时候去肯特万圣节？
Ryan texts back. We'll be there in an hour. An hour goes by. No Ryan. John texts again. Ryan texts back. We'll be there in another 15 minutes. No Ryan.
瑞恩回信息说。我们一小时内到。一个小时过去了。没有瑞恩。约翰又发信息。瑞恩回信息说。我们再过15分钟就到。没有瑞恩。
So he asks again. When you guys showing up at Kent Halloween, Ryan says, we're almost on our way or something that it goes on and on like this. And as John waits and drinks, the night just gets later and later and later. It starts out at 10 o'clock. It's 10, 30, 11, 30, 12, 30, 130, and I'm just, you know, waiting around at a bar. Ryan and his friends never come.
所以他又问。你们什么时候到肯特万圣节？瑞恩说，我们快在路上了或者诸如此类的话，事情就一直这样继续下去。当约翰一边等待一边喝酒时，夜晚变得越来越深。从10点开始。10点半、11点半、12点半、1点半，我只是，你知道的，在酒吧里闲逛。瑞恩和他的朋友们根本没有来。
And it turns out that they went somewhere else in town to go hang out and like I wasn't really invited to go around and that was like where things just fizzled out. I mean you must be really upset and heartbroken when this happened. Oh, me I think I was. I think I I think this is my senior year and I this is like the I goes about to graduate and you know I had so much like work I had to do and like I really was, I was depressed after this. I was totally devastated. Then it got worse. Ryan broke things off with John through a text.
结果证明他们去了镇上的其他地方闲逛，我并没有真正被邀请一起去，事情就是这样不了了之的。我的意思是，发生这种事你一定很难过心碎。哦，我，我想我是的。我想我，我想这是我的大四，我，这就像我要毕业了，你知道的，我有那么多工作要做，而且我真的，我在这之后很沮丧。我彻底崩溃了。然后事情变得更糟了。瑞恩通过一条短信和约翰分手了。
It wasn't even a text with actual words that he had written himself. He sent me like some sort of like, it was a gif. A gif, one of those tiny trivial video clips that runs in a loop. And it was basically said, I don't like you. And that was it. Oh, it's really painful, isn't it? It is very painful. And I think that's kind of set me down like, you know, other relationships. It's just kind of... It still stings a lot. And that's why I kind of really don't want. I just don't want to get hurt like that again.
甚至都不是他自己写的实际文字的短信。他给我发了某种，那是一个动图。一个动图，那种循环播放的微小琐碎视频剪辑之一。基本上就是说，我不喜欢你。事情就是这样。哦，这真的很痛苦，不是吗？非常痛苦。而且我认为这让我对之后的感情产生了……这仍然隐隐作痛。这就是为什么我真的不想。我只是不想再受到那样的伤害了。
After Ryan, John still held out hope for Finding Love. He poured his feelings out in songs that he had recorded, including this one that he wrote and posted on Facebook, not long after Halloween. He also went back on Grindr and met other guys. But when he got sick of all the one night stands, he started to have this dim sobering thought. You're probably not going to find anybody that you like in particular. Maybe there perhaps is nobody out there that's going to really kind of click with me and I kind of, I'm
在瑞恩之后，约翰仍然对寻找爱情抱有希望。他把自己的感情倾注在他录制的歌曲中，包括这首他在万圣节后不久创作并发布在Facebook上的歌。他还重新回到Grindr上认识其他男生。但当他对所有的艳遇感到厌倦时，他开始产生这种暗淡而清醒的想法。你可能找不到任何你特别喜欢的人。也许外面根本没有人能真正与我合拍，而我差不多，我对现状很满足。
satisfied with that. Here's why John is satisfied for now. Because about four times a week, he says he pulls out his phone and escapes into another world. Where all the texts are answered, the love is required, and everyone has great abs.
这就是为什么约翰目前感到满足。因为他说他每周大约有四次拿出手机，逃进另一个世界。在那里，所有的信息都有回复，爱情是必需的，而且每个人都有极好的腹肌。
Where it's clear who's gay and who's not. Where people have incredible sex. I'm talking, of course, about porn. Yeah, really? Maybe. It's right there and you have like, your tips to your fingers is like, you know, all video. I don't understand, I mean, like, you do griffin'
在那里，谁是同性恋一目了然。在那里，人们拥有不可思议的性爱。当然，我指的是色情片。是啊，真的吗？也许吧。它就在那里，触手可及，你知道的，全都是视频。我不明白，我是说，就像，你对人类记录……感觉如此。但大学怎么办？我不在乎，只要有你。但大学怎么办？我不在乎，只要有你。约翰说，出于很多原因，色情片比约会更容易。首先，它更便宜，通常是免费的。而且感觉毫不费力。如果有了男朋友，他得琢磨，
on the human record, it feels like. But what about college? I don't care, as long as I have you. But what about college? I don't care, as long as I have you. John says that for a lot of reasons, porn is easier than dating. For one thing, it's cheaper, it's usually free. And it feels effortless. With a boyfriend, he'd have to figure out,
这段感情会走向何方？这能持续多久？他真的喜欢我吗？然后男朋友开始提出各种要求，哦，你能不能也当我的银行账户，顺便帮我分担家务？所有这些事情。这是他不想要的压力和义务，他还有更紧急的事情要做。比如我必须，你知道的，现在建立我的职业生涯，还要还清贷款，并试图
where is this going? How long will this last? Does he really like me? And then the boyfriend will start making requests like, Oh, can you also be my bank account and also help me out with chores around the house? All this stuff. It's stress and obligations he doesn't want, and he's got more urgent things to do. Like I have to, you know, build up my career right now and also pay off my loans and try
弄清楚，我到底想不想买房，还有……还有别的东西。不像在酒吧或在Grindr上，屏幕上的人看不到你，他们不知道你是谁，约翰觉得这是一件好事。我是混血儿，所以很多有色人种在约会软件上时，找人更难，只是因为他们能看到你是谁。他们知道你长什么样。你不确定他们不喜欢你，是因为他们不喜欢你这个人，还是因为他们只是觉得你的种族不吸引人。
to figure out, do I want to buy a house or not and There's something else Unlike in a bar or on grinder the people on the screen Can't see you they don't know who you are which John feels is a good thing. I am mixed so A lot of people of color when you're on a dating app it is Harder to find people just because they can see who you are They know what you look like. You're not sure if like they don't like you because they don't like you as a person Or they don't like you because they just don't find you attractive because of your race
但相比之下，如果是色情片，如果你在色情片上挑肥拣瘦，那就不是什么大问题了。看色情片，没有人会被一张动图甩掉，也没有人会顶着哥特风亚当·兰伯特的妆容孤零零地留在酒吧里。没有人会心碎。在感情和关系方面，没有任何一团糟的事情。没有人受伤。我是说，看色情片可能也会伤感情，但是……
But then like versus porn if you if you discriminate on porn, it's not as big of an issue. With porn, nobody's dumped through a gif or left alone at a bar looking like Goth Adam Lambert. Nobody's heart gets broken. There's no kind of messiness when it comes to feelings and relationships. No feelings hurt. I mean, there probably are feelings hurt
约翰内心深处渴望真正的亲密关系。但正如他所说，他把这搁置了。你知道，我们总是梦想成为摇滚巨星，所以我们买了一把吉他，然后弹了一段时间。然后事情不顺利后，我们就把它放回琴盒里一段时间，然后等事情还是不顺利，我们就把它放回琴盒里一小会儿，希望也许等我们有更多时间了，我们可以把那东西
with pornography, but... John's two ones real intimacy. But as he says, he's put that on a shelf. You know, we always have like dreams of becoming like rock stars and so we buy a guitar and then we play it for a while. And then after things just not working out, we just put that in the case for a while and then after things just not working out we just put that in the case for a little bit and hopefully maybe when we get more time we can go take that thing
拿出来重新开始弹奏。我对人际关系就是这种感觉。这就像我并没有真正完全放弃。我有很多问题，但目前人际关系不必是其中之一。说到人际关系，约翰为了走到今天的地步付出了很多努力，他公开自己的性取向，愿意展开对话，准备在电影院里握住别人的手。但目前，看别人亲密相处只能暂且将就了。不过有时，他确实会质疑自己做出的交易，用真人换取虚拟人物。我觉得我失去了某些东西，但当我观看时，我就是说不出我失去了什么
out and start playing it again. That's kind of how I feel about relationships. It's like I haven't really given up completely. I have so many problems but a relationship doesn't have to be one of them right now. When it comes to relationships, John has worked hard to be where he is today, open about his sexuality, willing to start a conversation, ready to take someone's hand in a movie theater. But for now, watching other people be intimate will have to do. Sometimes though, he does wonder about the bargain he's made, trading real people for virtual ones. I feel I've lost something but I just can't name what I've lost when I do watch
色情片。当你承诺将其用作替代品，而不是真正地，你知道的，谈恋爱时，总觉得你失去了某种东西。我认为很大一部分是同理心，当你使用付费网站或任何不真实的东西时，这种交易中是没有同理心的。我们所有人都是一项非凡的、不受控制的实验中的新兵。没有人问过你想不想成为这个实验的一部分，而且你很难抽身。随着娱乐、幻想和专家的绝技通过屏幕和耳机流入我们的脑海，通过他人来生活变得越来越容易。对于替代生活是好是坏，没有简单的答案。
for. There's something it feels like you've lost when you've kind of committed to using it as a substitute, then actually, you know, being in a relationship. I think it's a lot of it is that the empathy of it, there's no empathy in that transaction when you're on a pay for site or anything that's not real. All of us are recruits in an extraordinary uncontrolled experiment. No one has asked you if you want to be part of this experiment, and it's hard to extricate yourself. As entertainment and fantasy and the feats of experts flow into our brains through our screens and headphones, it's easier and easier to live through other people. There is no simple answer to whether vicarious living is good or bad.
观看专家可以带来启发。它也可能消磨动力。也许真正的问题不是替代生活对你来说是好是坏。而是你是否在积极地选择它。对何时将屏幕变成生活的替代品保持审慎，意味着当时机成熟时，你也可以关掉那个屏幕。本期节目由劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕斯·沙阿（Path Shah）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、卡特·舒克内赫特（Kat Shuknecht）和鲁希克·瓦巴（Lushik Waba）。我们本周的幕后英雄是维罗妮卡·萨拉戈维亚（Veronica Zaragovia），她录制了我们对娜塔莉（Natalie）的采访，娜塔莉是我们的
Watching experts can inspire. It can also demotivate. Maybe the real question is not whether vicarious living is good or bad for you. It's whether you are actively choosing it. Being deliberate about when you turn a screen into a replacement for your life means that when the time is right, you also get to turn off that screen. This week's episode was produced by Laura Correll and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Path Shah, Thomas Liu, Kat Shuknecht and Lushik Waba. Our Ronsang hero this week is Veronica Zaragovia who recorded our interview with Natalie, our
来自佛罗里达的听众。那天天气很热，娜塔莉在车里接受了我们的采访。我们请他们关掉空调，这样杂音就不会被录进去。我们聊了几分钟，然后他们会暂停采访，打开空调降温。谢谢维罗妮卡关注这些小细节，
listener from Florida. It was a hot day and Natalie spoke to us from her car. We asked them to turn off the air conditioning so that the hiss wouldn't come through the recording. We would chat for a few minutes, and then they'd pause to turn on the air conditioning and cool things down. Thank you Veronica for sweating the small stuff
并让我们的节目听起来棒极了。如果你喜欢这期节目，请考虑把它分享给朋友，并帮他们订阅《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）。
and helping our shows sound great. If you liked this episode, please consider sharing it with a friend and help them to subscribe to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。